um
okay so thank you
thank you crowd for coming to our
workshop um basically um i um
um one of the directors of triple bottom
line accounting but i'm not an
accountant
and with the help of aleister who you've
just listened to on the panel and from
maple cone we've been developing an esg
impact narrative tool
and our idea is to absolutely simplify
this and make it and break all the
barriers that are stopping very busy
small businesses from trying to do
something about it so you you hear the
jargon you see that you've got to pass
these certain accreditations or targets
and you're just too busy to even get
your head around that and even know how
to start so it's all about starting
starting that journey
and so um what we we're rolling out is a
very simple and affordable way to start
working out how you you know what your
what your carbon we're talking about
carbon today so what your carbon
emissions are um and
how you can reduce them so we just
wanted um we're not going to get through
the whole thing today in 15 minutes but
um this is kind of what we'd like to do
um we we're going to show you the triple
bottom line um carbon foot report from
the 12 months of 2020 and we're not
going to tell you what we decided to do
to reduce our carbon footprint we can at
the end and we can send you the
powerpoint if we don't get there we're
going to ask you to tell us what you
think we could do so imagine this was
our current you know our current
situation
and really get that sort of um the ideas
flowing but it'd be really really useful
we haven't got a lot of time if you
could um perhaps just um tell us if we
went around the room
what you think for your business might
be the biggest challenge relevant to
climate change the thing that the
biggest obstacle or challenge would
anybody like to just kick that off very
very quickly
um would you anyone here from that is a
sme um no nobody here from sn
yeah
i was here representing a community
group it's been called yeah like my
song
business
soldier business
really if i'm moving online
then the biggest impact of that is all
of that
infrastructure and so on how sustainable
is that because you know i used to be an
environmental science teacher i don't
think it's particularly sustainable but
it's it's how we are it's a real dilemma
of where your ethnic lies
and where reality and where you get
income from
um
i think that's a really good point and
for us as an accountancy business you'll
see that our biggest in the moment
you'll see that our biggest emissions
are our scope 3 emissions which i'll
explain if anyone needs to
that explainer in a minute which is
basically we buy in a lot of software
um and that software the servers are in
the cloud somewhere probably in the
virginia corridor in the usa and
probably managed by amazon web services
and and most likely powered by fossil
fuel okay
so
i think what you think about it doesn't
take much to dig beneath
you you know
we've all got our mobile phones you know
that there's a huge rare earth you know
metals all those things yeah okay does
anyone else got an obstacle that they
can see at the moment yeah it can um go
ahead so i'm andrew summers uh transport
east um okay so we're a partnership of
local authorities business organizations
there's only four of us in the team
um it's art
angles so in terms of our core business
it is to decarbonize transport in the
east of england through investment and
i guess from this perspective business
travel a lot of businesses have told us
it's the um
car use
for the commute for example and then act
through everyday business how do you
change your fleets to that mission so
two really good things there but
how do you change your car using really
resonates with us as team four could say
well you know
you do how do you get places like this
but our everyday everyday business is
going out to me across the region how
can we do that sustainably basically in
places that have poor personal
transportation buses there yeah
and not everyone has an electric car yet
how do you
um commute to engaging places in a more
sustainable way so yeah no it's it's a
really good point hopefully we can come
back to that in a moment you know
yes sorry yeah i was just going to add
once i moved
district council okay but as a business
we own a huge amount of social housing
we need to look at decarbonizing the the
socializing stock that we own in terms
of making it more energy efficient and
and suitable for homes in the future
looking at energy production and energy
storage and making sure that the houses
are
are safe and sustainable but we also
have a massive wastewater we have just
committed to using
waste oil to power that that waste fleet
but
we all require proof that we are a
fairly large business and we have a lot
of different services that we have to
invest in each one of those services
has got multiple facets that we have to
try and unpick
in order to be able to change the way
the business operates yeah yeah
okay so so one of the things that we we
talk to our customers about is well
you've got to look at what you've got to
do but you also look at what you've done
yeah okay and you start thinking like i
have started but then how can we
feasibly do all those things we're not
going to do them all in 12 months so
you know what's what's uh what are the
low hanging fruit perhaps that we can
tackle first to get on that journey so
i'll come back to some of that um as
well
so um
i won't go through all the introductions
but we had this um
statistic repeated throughout the day
which is that 99
um of all uk business and industry is
smes and the
the total emissions of business and
industry in the uk is the 25 of all our
emissions come from business and
industry so um i i say to our clients it
doesn't matter how small you are we've
all got a part to pay it's a whole
systems approach here um and that's a
whole system approach to public
transport to to efficiency in in social
housing or whatever it might be
um
i don't know if anybody's familiar with
the term scope 1 scope 2 and scope 3.
a lot of people just measure their scope
one and two and co2e emissions so the
co2e and all emissions but you can see
the emissions across the top of the
screen there that are equivalent to um
the the impact of co2
so um
we say that your your scope one your
direct once it's it's actually like what
you're what fossil fuel perhaps you're
burning in your building so gas is the
most obvious one yeah okay
and scope two for us as an accountancy
practice um is the electricity so
obviously it's burnt elsewhere but we're
using that that power in our in our
building to to power up all our devices
and
and that sort of thing
and scope three can be up
stream and downstream um and we work in
a very energy efficient building in fact
it has been plugged as the most energy
it's a passive house building a business
hub the most energy efficient or the
greenest building i think is what they
call it in the whole of europe
so our emissions are quite low at scope
one and scope two
um but they are enormous when we look at
our supply chain
in particular the scope three so for us
that's where we've got to concentrate
because that's we're making a big impact
and the last thing i just wanted to to
quickly say is this question i quite
often get asked in you know workshops
and webinars is okay i run a business
and i really really want to do this but
how do i get my team on board and my
team might be my management team or if
you're a small business it might be your
whole 5 10 15 employees yeah and it's
only going to work if you get them on
board so i love this graphic because um
it's about
having to inform them and this is what
we do in our target setting workshops we
work with your whole team and we say
let's just the facts what are the facts
about climate change how serious is this
really make it really understandable and
consult with all your stakeholders
ideally but start off with your team
your employees
and
you know what would they like to do what
can we do together
and whatever you come up with is your
targets and your action plans you need
to have that consent of everybody and if
the ideas are coming from them
then you've automatically got that
buy-in and then you empower them to do
it and they become part of that change
and they become proud of that change so
one of our mottos is what's your story
are you proud of what you do yeah and
sometimes we think we haven't done
enough good but actually we have yeah
um and we all can do more so alistair
i'm just going to um
pass on the the mic
to you um
there and
there
is going to talk you through aleister
worked as an external consultant for our
business although we are collaborating
on this it was good to have somebody
from outside our team talk to our staff
rather than the bosses talking to the
staff got someone out there who can say
okay we've measured the carbon footprint
this is what we've got
what are we going to do as a team you
know fantastic two hours we did it
online during the pandemic and got total
buy-in
so looking at the um
the tbla's carbon footprint
we did some analysis
of what the
of
the
the purchases and the sales and etc etc
that the tbla were doing
in order to make some assessment of the
um upstream and downstream um scope 3
emissions and also understood from the
building itself what the scope 1 scope 2
emissions were so we ended up with the
um we ended up with um
a
a breakdown like this which um i
appreciate the text is a bit small so um
we will move on to this one which
demonstrates the fact that what uh frank
was just saying which is scope three
emissions dwarf the scope one and scope
two emissions
kind of expected because of the nature
of the uh of the organization and the
office that it um it's in um but
um what was interesting was the fact
that it was only 1.8 tons per employee
which is actually really quite low so
you know credit for two to tbla for that
they've already um quite a long way down
down the journey
but they've all they're starting
starting from a good place should we say
but they've
got some got some work to do to get to
the last bit
so the interest really comes into scope
three and a lot of people try and ignore
scope 3 but i firmly believe that
actually we should look at scope 3
because it's all very well saying scope
3 are somebody else's problem but i
don't think they are
scope 3 is something that you can do
things about
and looking at the scope 3 it's very
obvious that
purchases
of all sorts of stuff
and i'll come into that in a minute
purchases account for about 50
of the scope 3 emissions um
and then the other the other half is
roughly divided between the commuting
emissions and the home working emissions
so
this was measured
[Music]
part way through the pandemic so we had
to make an allowance for the fact that
um
past of the year was during pre-pandemic
so there was commuting going on and the
past of the year was during pandemic so
there was homework going on but that was
interesting in itself
because obviously there's there is a
little bit of a
challenge going on there as to some some
organizations are thinking well should
we actually
not have an office and have everybody
working at home because that would mean
we touch the office and save all the
heating associated with the office but
actually then you're substituting
everybody's heating at home certainly
during the winter months maybe the
answer is that everybody works at home
during the summer and then works in the
office in the winter i don't know i'm
really interested about the homework
versus commuting
yeah
because
inherently sort of think of people
accusing their saving carbon
but
that home working was possibly a bit
higher than i think it might be
yeah just wondering how different does
that look before the pandemic
well yes we don't have those figures but
it's really
interesting that um
we had sort of like march march to
august
do you have a seat but we were all
working from home
and then in august because we got quite
a young team and they were really
missing that social interaction we had
to weigh up not just the environmental
impact but their mental well-being as
well okay they needed to be interacting
with each other and just seeing a head
on the screen wasn't the same so we
we've got commuting going on from
january to march and from august um to
to december although less people
commuted in that time because we had the
hybrid model
because you're working with your office
is a pacifist office yeah you're
incredibly energy efficient
are you then assessing the people's home
will talk about but yes um initially
when you start this journey you have no
idea how each person is um
getting their energy in their homes or
how well insulated their homes are and
all those other parts of that equation
and and also
you then start to get into some
interesting questions as to
is it the imp is it part of the
employer's role to start to influence
the employee or to have that debate with
the employee as to whether they ought to
be buying a green tariff or not
i'll leave the question hanging
but it's an interesting question um and
it's but it's but having but my thought
is on that subject is that i think it's
worth it's having the dialogue that's
important
raising the awareness that's important
which is back to a previous slide that
the fran talked about it's
having that dialogue and raising the
importance of it and getting people to
start to think about these things
because if you don't start to think
about them then
things don't happen and you're
presumably modeling it as well you're
modeling yeah we ask you exactly we ask
we ask people
how do they get to work
how far do they come
and we asked them what sort of house do
you live in or flat do you live in
and
do you have a green tariff well do you
not have a green tariff and that was it
we
from there we approximated we heard
earlier today there's no point in going
after the sixth small place really is
irrelevant you know the guy from um the
the
malting company said you know it's you
know it's absolutely better to be
approximately right you know that's good
enough it's fine we we know that
purchases are a big issue we know that
home working um is something that we
need to think about we know that
commuting is something that we need to
think about but the big one is
purchasing
so if we go on to the next slide which
uh also expand this slide it's just
interesting to see
um
the split between cars and buses for
example the majority of that is cars
mainly because there was a relatively
small number of people using the bus but
also they were traveling a relatively
short distance and it's much more
efficient from the carbon point of view
home energy heating was the large
majority of it
um
where you can try and do the calculation
in my head but you know sort of eight
times or something
the the electricity um uh carbon
and then when it comes to purchasing
this was all done through economic
modelling
so
looking at
an amount spent on for example
advertising was probably going to
produce a
a carbon uh emission of x kilograms
whatever it was so it's just really it's
it's it's an approximation but it gives
us an indication as to whether where
so that brings us to the
exam question for today
what would we do about it
what should we do about it what are your
thoughts
[Music]
you know and think about it in the
context of your own organizations or
your own you know lives as well and
what what could it be so what do you
think i'll put this slide back up now
you know what the question is um
yeah absolutely
good good thought yes procurement policy
now in place yeah and it's sustainable
it's published on our website if you go
on to website you can see it in the
footer with all the policies and it's
very clear and it's also actionable
yeah that
kind of knuckle effect in terms of the
cost of some of the things that you're
procuring
and you might reduce your emissions but
increase your corporate cost
yes and no because if you're buying more
locally yeah okay what what what we've
lost is is the instant gratification
i can i can order something from amazon
and get it in less than 24 hours i might
need a new lead for a new member of
staff staff's new laptop or something
like that and we haven't got the right
connector for it okay but actually we
can make do for a couple of days and get
it more locally by not using amazon and
i know amazon was used a lot today and i
know there's a there's a lot of
good things that they're doing but
they're still outweighed by the social
and environmental and unimpressive
things that are happening at amazon
quite honestly so i you know we we
actually do boycott amazon
full stop and that's part of our
procurement policy yeah
not amazing
i think education yes
very much so yes and that's education of
advertising of people how to use
buildings and what is about and what the
future is we don't do
what we
like to do yes and actually how can we
do what we can when you say people from
the point of view of an sme such as a
small accounting practice what people
should we be educating
customers and visitors
yeah yeah supply chain
investors
fell i think yes and
one of the big advantages doing doing
all of this is that it makes the
organization that much more attractive
to all of those stakeholders isn't it
more attractive to buy from more
attractive to work for more attractive
to invest your money in so
it's lots of tips to do this sort of
thing
within the commuting
um
i guess there's a number of things that
you might have done um
emerging sustainable transport loans
offering incentives to start to
travel by
because we're running out of time so um
the purchasing policy was our chief big
thing because that's going to make a
difference
and i will just say before i answer the
question because i think someone's going
to come in in a minute and one of the
things that we can do with our supply
chain and part of the education thing is
that we can lobby them we can say like
we're not going to stop buying from you
because we need that bookkeeping
software or we need that accountancy
program because we're not going to stop
buying it but we are going to start
thinking about you know where we might
buy in the future what what is your
program have you got a net zero program
and if you have we don't mind that
you're not carbon neutral or net zero
yet but the fact that you're on that
journey makes you more favorable so
we're really pushing that way
um but in terms of the commuting okay
and interestingly the shortest distance
that two of our members of staff have to
come we're now 12
and they take the bus but they have to
go from outside the city into the city
to change bus to come out of the city so
they actually make the longest journey
so that's crazy yeah
um so we are gradually introducing um
octopus energy you've got a new scheme i
don't know if you've heard of it but
it's octopus ev
and they do everything for the employer
and the employee
so it's an end-to-end service so we will
be leasing cars we've actually just
started doing it for our employees
that need a car um to commute to work
and they get a brand new car the tax
incentive incentives for for small
businesses are amazing and the benefit
in kind
tax to the employee is very minimal
still
and and therefore and they get a charger
put in everything yeah okay i realized
we need to do i'm sorry
okay yeah so just just to add to that
our moral dilemma with that is is that
fair for the people who walk in and
cycle in because they only live down the
road yeah okay
so it's looking at yes they'll take a
salary sacrifice
um in order to get a brand new
to come to work
but
other people need to have something in
the equivalent of that to make it fair
okay so if the
if if what they're getting is what say
two thousand pounds a year
um you know upscale you know upgrading
their pay then what's on offer for the
people who don't want or need a car so
that it's not an easy solution and it's
not the only solution because neighbor
or i believe that evs are the solution
absolutely not there are so many
environmental problems with electrical
negative we're fully aware of that and
the the dream would be and it's been
touched on today
is a probably integrated sustainable
transport system if i go to work in my
ev i do i do my husband and i both we
have a company ev already
um
it's a 25 mile commute okay 45 minute
drive if i go on the train or bus the
end to end journey
round commute is four hours
and that doesn't include the waiting
time yeah okay or the late bus or the
train that gets cancelled just as you
get to the station and i can walk to the
station in 20 minutes beautiful walk
along a beautiful
footpath
um and so i enjoy it it's good for my
well-being yeah but then it's still
going to be two hours end to end by the
time we get to the train station and
wait for the bus that's going to take me
to the uea get off that bus walk to work
so it's not comparable i need to get to
work i prefer working from home for that
reason but i need to be seeing the staff
as well
so there's lots more we can say and um
we we have got our solutions you can
actually find them on our website we do
have our whole action plan on our carbon
footprint footprint report and you can
see what we did we are a carbon neutral
company but what we want to be is a net
zero company
i don't have anything else that you
wanted to stress no i think it's
it's a it's a really interesting journey
for every organization to go down
but the the two things i would would say
is number one is start
start and start small keep it simple
don't try and solve all the problems you
know you know and don't try and do
everything start by doing the really the
simple stuff even if that's only
changing all of the bulbs to leds um as
they blow
to reduce the um reduce the energy
consumption of the building whatever it
is
influence your supply chain and
influence um influence your landlord
it's it's all of those things that we
can do but keep it simple and get but do
start and we're here to help if every
time yeah um if you'd like our pack of
slides which actually simplifies the
process um i think the easiest thing is
um pick up a flyer from our store which
has got our emails really um easy to
find triple bottom line accounting
okay um and uh triple bottomline
accounting.com or just pick up a leaflet
which explains our service as well and
we'll email you um the pack which just
shows you what we actually did choose to
do and pretty much um the ideas that
you've suggested so thank you thank you